في موضوع اخر قال رئيس تونسي قيس سعيد في
لقاء مع رئيسه الحكومه انه يتواصل مع
اجهزه الدوله باستمرار خلافا لما تم
تداوله في الايام الاخيره ووصف سعيد
الشائعات التي تحدثت عن غيابه بانها بلغت
درجه من الجنون لم تعرفها تونس من قبل
مؤكدا ان مروجيها لا يفرقون بين حاله
الشهور وغيرها لان هدفهم هو احداث حاله
الشغور على حد تعبيره
مرحبا بك السيده رئيسه الحكومه في هذا
اللقاء المباشر بالرغم من ان
المكالمات كانت متواصله
هو مستمره والتنسيق مستمر بين كل اجهزه
الدوله عكس ما يتم ترويج له تقريبا بلغه
درجه من درجات الجنون التي لم نعرفها في
تونس من قبل
تونس مدير مكتب الجزيره لطفي حاجي ماذا
حول هذا الجزء القائم حاليا حول وضع
الرئيس سعيد والى مدى بهذا اللقاء هو قطع
الشك باليقين فيما يتعلق بوضعه وحالتها
الصحيه
بالفعل هو هذا الفيديو وهذا الظهور بعد
عشره ايام وضع حدا لهذا
الجدل والرئيس خصص 11 دقيقه للرد على من
يعتبرهم مروجين اشاعات في هذه
في هذا الموضوع بالذات واعتبر ان حتى هناك
من الخبراء من تحدث عن الشهور المؤقت
وصغور الدائم وتحدث عن مستقبل الدوله
اعتبر ان هؤلاء لا يميزون بين حالات
الشهور في القانون وضرب امثله بذلك عاد
حتى الى الستينات في عهد بوركيبا لممردا
واوكل مهامه الى الوزير الاول البيئي قدم
نماذج بذلك لكن لافته ان قيس سعيد لم يشر
الى مرضه في هذا الفيديو لكن كانت هناك
جمله قالها وكانه اصيب باللهجه التونسيه
بهواء يعني بنزله برد فهذا الاشاره
الوحيده فقط لهذا المرض لكن واضح ان هذا
الصعود هو وضع حد لجدل لانه جدل
ارتفع خاصه في اليومين الاخرين للحديث عن
وهناك تناقل لبرقيات وكاله الانبياء خارج
خاصه لايطاليه هناك احد الوكالات الانباء
الايطاليه التي تنشر كل يوم تقريبا برقيه
عن حاله واشارت انه
في القلب غير ذلك واليوم اشرت انه يتعافى
ويمكن ان يرجع يوم الاربعاء وهناك من
المعارضه من طالب اليوم
بالحكومه او رئاسه الجمهوريه باصدار بيان
لتوضيح الامر وتوضيح الحاله الصحيه لرئيس
الدوله الحاله الصحيه لرئيس الدوله واي
رئيس دوله ليست حاله فرديه شخصيه تهم فقط
وانما هي تهم البلاد كافه هناك من عاد الى
الدستور وفصول الدستور وكيف ينظم السلطه
في حاله الشغل لكن واضح ان هذا الفيديو
وضع حدا لانهاء هذا الجدل بظهوره الاول
بعد غياب اكثر من 10 ايام نعم اشكرك لطفي
مديره مكتب الجزيره كنت معنا من تونس